hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his short treaties on the anger of
God lockedancius is going to single out
two philosophical schools of antiquity
for particular criticism saying that
they essentially get God and the
emotions wrong and he thinks that the
epicureans who we're going to talk about
here are more wrong than the stoics but
they're both wrong in their views on God
and the epicureans were a major School
of antiquity lactancius would have been
well you know acquainted with their
Works many of which he had access to but
we don't have access to anymore so
presumably he's you know looked at their
perspective quite closely and we're
going to see the criticisms that he's
going to make are
on point and quite interesting he's also
going to draw in Cicero and postedonius
and others to criticize them as well
Shoring up his position so it begins in
chapter four and the Very title of
chapter four includes the phrase the
censure of epicurus meaning here I'm
going to tell you how epicurus got
things wrong and he begins by saying
what epicurus is doing is taking away
Anger from God saying God or the gods
cannot be angry and thereby taking away
kindness as well which translates both
grazia and beneficentia two very
important terms being good to human
beings so he says epicurus thought it
was inconsistent with God to injure and
to inflict harm which for the most part
arises from the effect section of anger
so he said you know God wouldn't be that
sort of being and this is actually in
the Epicurean documents that we still do
have preserved like the you know
principal doctrines uh the uh Vatican
sayings and things like that God doesn't
get so attached to things as to get
angry at us and so la tancius is going
to say the epicureans think of anger as
a vice at least anger in the sense of
like injuring others and that sort of
affect and he says by not conceding
advice
to God they're also however taking away
a virtue a good trait that we could
ascribe to God so in a way if you've
ever heard that familiar saying throwing
the baby out with the bath water that is
what he's saying epicurus is doing uh he
goes on he says because God is happy and
corrupted because he cares about nothing
neither takes trouble himself nor
occasions it's to another this is the
Epicurean point of view of God and how
does epicurus arrive at this sort of
perspective well lactancia says that he
follows out a initial starting point of
putting capio
of a probability of an opinion
probability is very similar tudo looking
like truth that comes from the word you
know veres
Veris meaning true and then simulator a
likeness to truth but not really being
true so a probability of an opinion
sentencia a point of view you might say
and is going to use this term in in a
verbal form as well In this passage so
he goes on and he says he's LED from the
beginning by this probability of an
opinion he necessarily fell into those
things which followed so you start with
a mistaken assumption uh mistaken
opinion and then you're going to draw
some conclusions from that and well what
were what was the first opinion anger's
not consistent with the character of God
and then when this appeared to him to be
true and unassailable he was unable to
refuse the consequences one affection
being removed One affect necessity
compelled him to remove from God the
other factions also and the ones that he
mentions here are you know anger
kindness but also fear God doesn't feel
fear Joy like titsia
grief pity this is a very important one
for Christians and particular and then
in chapter 16 he will expand this to
talking about God not feeling desire or
libido not feeling Envy Nvidia or greed
avaricia sometimes it's translated as
avarice and luxonsius is actually going
to say you know we need to look at this
quite carefully it could be that God
actually does feel some of these and
doesn't feel others and lactancius's
basic point of view on this which we've
talked about elsewhere at greater length
is that God does feel emotions emotions
that stem from virtue and express virtue
which include anger anger at those who
are doing wrong who violate or show
contempt for the Divine Law and are
damaging the universe and other beings
right God doesn't feel fear because
there's nothing for God to fear God
doesn't feel pity or grief rather God
does feel pity Misericordia right but
God also doesn't feel libido God doesn't
want to have sex with anybody uh Envy or
greed God's got everything already right
so
um epicurus went wrong in thinking that
if you take away one emotion because all
the emotions are connected with each
other that you have to take away all the
rest of the emotions so take away anger
they all go and lactancius is showing us
well no that's not really the case we
need a better differentiated analysis of
what emotions it makes sense for God to
feel so that's one line of criticism
the next line of criticism comes up in
chapter four is reinforced in chapter
seven and then comes up again in chapter
17 and we've already gotten a little
taste of it you know in saying that God
is uh you know not caring about anything
not taking trouble
um
well lachtancius is going to say
he's not really much of a God if he's
neither moved nor does anything
impossible for human beings if he
doesn't care about things if he's always
inactive right so you know the
epicureans are saying the gods exactly
why the gods or gods or God is Happy is
because they don't care they're not
bothered with all of this mundane crap
that us human beings get ourselves bound
up with they exist somewhere else and
they they don't engage with the rest of
the universe and that's why they're
blessed and lactancias and other people
in ancient philosophy as well were like
not much of a God then is it why even
bother calling this uh God and you know
he says that you know epicurus
um you know probably wanted to say well
there has to be some sort of blessed
being in the universe but if we think
this through
what is actually
intrinsic to the idea of God so the
Epicurean God would have no will no
voluntas
no action no governance Administration
gubernacio is another term that gets
used and doesn't care about anything
doesn't show any concern for the
universe or the creatures of the
universe and he brings in Cicero and
postedonius
he says
Marcus tulius relates that it was said
by postedonius epicurus understood there
were no Gods but he'd said those things
he spoke respecting the gods for the
sake of driving away odium so he leaves
the Gods in words but takes away them in
reality because he gives them no motion
no office no function to them right this
is a God or gods that do nothing so it
may as well be a kind of atheism and in
uh you know a little bit later in
chapter seven he's going to talk about
this as a rejection of religion he says
epicurus says this and this is actually
coming from lucretius for the nature of
the Gods Must ever in itself of
necessity enjoy immortality together
with Supreme Repose far removed and
withdrawn from our concerns exempt from
any pain exempt from dangers strong in
its own resources not wanting any
anything from us it's neither gained by
favors nor moved by anger lachtancia
says well when you say these things
clearly you don't think that you should
worship God or you know anything else
and this entirely overthrows as he says
religion he actually quote Cicero
farewell to God if he is such as to be
influenced by no favor and by no
affection of men and so he goes on a
little bit further and he says when
epicurus entertains these sentiments he
altogether destroys religion when this
is taken away confusion and perturbation
of life will follow right so he's
essentially saying and Cicero by the way
believes something like this as well
take away religion and everything's
going to fall apart I'm not sure whether
we buy that or not but there's a you
know more interesting argument that's
made in uh four and seven and 17 that
God's very activity
because God is active is to be concerned
with the universe and what's happening
in it all the way down to individuals
and this is why God will get angry at
those who are doing things that they
shouldn't be doing so a little bit later
this is in chapter 17 he says
um
Eternal rest belongs to death alone if
death does not affect God it follows God
is never at rest but what and what can
the action of God consist what does God
actually do the administration as we saw
again of the world if God carries on the
care of the world it follows he cares
for the life of human beings and he
takes notice of the acts of individuals
and he earnestly desires they should be
wise and good this is the will of God
the voluntas right the Divine Law he who
follows and observes this is beloved by
God God feels you know happiness love
towards those right he's also moved with
anger against the person who's broken or
despise this Divine Law right because
they are screwing things up so again a
rejection of the Epicurean conception of
God not really much of a god with the
consequences that again God could feel
anger finally we get this very
interesting consideration of the
argument from Evil if you're you know
used to the way in which it gets
presented in textbooks like an intro to
philosophy or philosophy of religion
epicurus's formulation is a little bit
different it's framed in terms of
willing you know Volare and being able
to which is
um
right protest here in this case and so
how does it run he says all right you
basically have four choices
either as he's going to say God either
wishes to take away evils
right to take away them from us human
beings so we don't suffer he's either uh
willing to he either wishes to take away
evils and is not able to do so right so
he uh desires he chooses but he can't do
what he chooses to do
if that's the case he's not much of a
God now he's he's feeble he's weak not
somebody that we should actually
consider worthy of worship
um or he's able and he's unwilling well
if that's the case and lactancia says
that epicurus is saying then God is
envious of us but we could just say if
God you know is capable of taking away
evil and doesn't want to do it God's
kind of a prick right uh you know why
why impose that he's not a good God then
in which case we shouldn't worship him
right
um or he's he's unable and unwilling at
the same time in which case he's both of
these things or the fourth option is he
is able to take away evils and he also
wishes to take away evils and then you
can say well
why are there so many bad things why are
there bad people doing bad things why
are there natural disasters why do we
suffer disease and famine and all these
other or you know awful uh possibilities
if God really cares about us why doesn't
he fix things
and there's a lot of different answers
to this in the history of theology has a
very interesting one here where he says
that um
God is able to do what he wants so
there's no weakness or Envy in God
he is there able therefore to take away
evils but he doesn't wish to do so but
he's not on that account envious why he
why doesn't he take them away because he
gives us wisdom and there's more of
goodness and pleasure and wisdom than of
annoyance and evils this allows us to
know God how does how does God give us
wisdom well wisdom you know God puts
evil and good things in front of us and
then we have to choose and think our way
between them that's what wisdom consists
in and wisdom can lead us to connecting
with God so it's a greater good than the
evils we encounter so he says unless we
first know evil we shall be unable to
know good epicurus didn't say this
nor did any other that if Evils are
taken away wisdom is in like manner
taken away no traces of virtue remain in
man the nature of which consists in
enduring and overcoming the bitterness
of evils so again he's saying something
kind of similar epicurus went wrong in
his reasoning not because he was a bad
guy or anything but he made some
mistaken assumptions didn't see the
connection of things and how things are
really set up within the universe in
relation to God and thereby wound up
making some significant mistakes so
these are the main criticisms of
epicurus and the Epicurean school that
we're going to see coming up in
loctanius's treaties on the anger of God
where he's rejecting and criticizing
this Epicurean position